bienvenue à paroles autochtone c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine
d'une question de sallanches qui me
demandent comment est ce que les parents
éduquer leurs enfants chez les premières
nations à ce qu'il paraîtrait il était
beaucoup plus permissif selon la
question est bonne ça va être très
difficile de pouvoir basée sur des
textes de l'anthropologie parce qu'à
l'époque on peut juste se baser sur je
dirais les textes sont venues des
premiers contacts avec les européens
mais ce que ce qui m'a le plus marqué à
l'époque c'est justement il disait que
nous en a été beaucoup plus libre
beaucoup plus sérieusement laissés à
eux-mêmes et mais une phrase qui avait
ressorti c'était mais il aime vraiment
beaucoup leurs enfants est ce ça peut
être dû au fait qu'on en avait peut-être
moins qu'en europe on sent pas qu'à
l'époque le taux de mortalité dans les
grandes villes européennes étaient quand
même très élevée chez les enfants à 25
ans et on était des nomades donc souvent
les nombres d'enfants étaient beaucoup
plus petit je pense que c'est une raison
qu'on va aimer ce qu'on a pu mais la
liberté c'est surtout une liberté
d'apprendre une liberté d'explorer
autour de soi son territoire touché le
feu par un conte qui brûlent faire
attention suivent et regarder ce qui est
autour de toi parce que tu vas devoir
devenir autonome très rapidement sur va
devoir prendre des responsabilités
autour de ton clan damnation de ta
famille et ça je pense que plus tu veux
contrôler comme un enfant habite son
espace puis - votre pouvoir justement se
remplir de ce territoire
donc moi je pense que cette liberté
était vraiment dû à une obligation de
grandir rapidement et de pour devenir
utile à la communauté rapidement et
l'amour ben je pense que si ça parle
juste de nos valeurs et j'espère que je
pense que les européens eux aussi
devaient aimer leurs enfants mais
peut-être que cette liberté là est
justement cette affection pour montrer l
a expiré justement la relation que les
européens eux mêmes et on recommence à
avoir avec leurs enfants
donc en espérant que la question lui a
pu être répondu aujourd'hui et que vous
allez nous en envoyer dans l'espace
autochtone je souhaite une très belle
semaine